hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll space
as you may have heard is the final
frontier but Frontiers are tricky places
Frontiers are celebrated in stories as
places where there is a bit of
lawlessness a bit of jockeying for
position not necessarily clear on what
the rules are all the time so do we want
space to be like that both thinking
about space right now there's a lot
going on in space there's a lot of
satellites out there doing weather and
Communications and so forth and there's
also the future of space so we might
send more human beings into space both
space stations but also the Moon Mars
and Beyond so today's guest is timiebe
aganaba who is a space lawyer she's
actually much more than that uh Tamia
Bay has worked in government in law
practice in Consulting and now as an
academic at Arizona State University
she's originally from Nigeria and has
also worked in the UK France Canada
before 5 only coming to the USA and
she's an expert in exactly these
questions of space governance as well as
space law governance if we think of
working together right there are both
strict rules that are encoded in laws
but then there are also norms and
expectations that we have and space in
some sense we might want to be sort of a
common resource to all of us a common
good as the economist would say but of
course other people want to clean little
bits of it for themselves so how do we
balance these things this is a question
for corporations as well as for Nations
and non-government organizations and so
forth and it is a frontier it very much
is the rules are not settled there are
space treaties the United Nations has
tried to set up some basic rules but the
rules are in flux we're not sure where
it's going and this is a good time to
think about these things with burgeoning
private exploration of space Timmy have
a one of her previous jobs was executive
director of the world base week
Association and World space week is
October 4 to 10 every year so we're
releasing this podcast at the beginning
of a new world space week to celebrate
exactly that so with that let's go
[Music]
welcome to the mindscape podcast
it is my honor and pleasure to be here
we're very happy to have you here space
the final frontier Etc is a is a very
exciting topic that we don't we don't
actually it's
ironically more down to earth than many
of the topics that we talk about here on
the podcast I mean you're involved with
law and things like that but you in the
talk I heard you give you drew a
distinction between space law and space
governance what what is the difference
there
yeah that's a really interesting
um interesting question because I mean I
did my PhD in in space law my first job
was as a lawyer the Nigerian space
agency
um so over the course of my 15-year
career you you see a lot about space law
yeah and I will go into that as to what
it is but over the past say five years
or so was starting to shift on language
to space governance because law has a
defined meaning kind of like it's
instruments right that a binding that
people agree to that if you if you
breach them there's some kind of
accountability
Etc but governance is everything else
that deals with how people operate and
why they do what they do
so for instance we could have a general
principle or we could have a guideline
right that is not a law but everyone
follows it and everyone does it because
it's in their best interest for a
particular you know activity
um we talk about the intentionality of
actors and sometimes there's nothing
forcing people to do a certain thing but
maybe because of the way they interact
with each other the way they get along
so that's kind of governance as well
right so what inspires and motivates
people to do certain things and that's
where I think the trend is going now
because we know that it's not so much
about saying just because something is
legal or illegal people do or don't do
it right there are other factors at Bay
and that's what I study good so if I can
just oversimplify it a little bit to get
into my head I mean law we have a set of
laws and you obey them or you don't
whereas governance is maybe a bit more
about thinking things through in a
hopefully collectively good kind of way
without quite such hard and fast
boundaries between yes and no
exactly and of course if you there's no
proper definition of governance and lots
of people are going to have different
ways everyone's heard of corporate
governance so that would be like how do
companies organize themselves like do
you have a board of directors do you
have stakeholder decision making there
are things like that on a formal level
but that's not what I'm talking about
when I talk about governance I'm talking
about the interrelations and the
interactions between stakeholders when
they decide what they should and should
not do is there a bit of issue that we
don't know who is in charge when it
comes to space and therefore laws are
going to be harder to be the guiding
principles
well it's not of course when it comes to
um what countries are bound by because
if you're talking about space law
historically it's just been States
states have been the biggest actors in
space and of course a state is Sovereign
there is no Authority that is higher
than the United States government right
like there is no Authority higher than
the Nigerian government so states have
to choose to be bound there's no
Authority above the state that can make
the state do something or the other you
do people have said well what about the
United Nations and we've all heard about
the security Council right the Security
Council is that group of Mega states
that can kind of put sanctions on other
countries and say you can do this or you
can do that that is still not I mean
it's obviously a mechanism that guides
the behavior of States but it's not like
the police that like yeah you know stay
states have to do it yeah so yeah so
maybe it's it's a reflection of the
reality that we are hoping that a whole
bunch of different kinds of actors can
get together to act the right way when
they get when it comes to space
yeah and of course I mean at the United
Nations there is a committee called the
committee on the peaceful uses of outer
space
um where there's up to a hundred states
that are members of that committee and
they basically you know the first space
law instruments were negotiated there
and States go every year to Geneva and
or Vienna sorry and you know discuss
developments in space so there is an
international mechanism so when people
say space is like the Wild Wild West
that's not true there's a whole system
of governance around thinking about this
the question is just is the existing
system that was established in the 60s
and 70s fit for the kinds of activities
we're seeing today since the explosion
of companies like SpaceX yeah good okay
good so uh that was very very helpful
but I want to get like a lot of
background in here because I think that
probably different people have different
ideas that pop right into their heads
when you talk about space law or space
governance one one question is are we
mostly thinking about
satellites in orbit around the Earth
right now communication satellites
weather satellites and what have you and
how to deal with those and space debris
and so forth or are we mostly thinking
about someday we'll have settlements on
Mars and we've got to figure out how to
govern them
yes now those are two very distinct
things yeah that people talk about the
things in the news you know stuff like
space settlements and things like that I
mean there are a few people who think
about the implications of that kind of
stuff and it is not that much science
fiction because for an example SpaceX in
the I mean they they could say it was a
joke but in their terms of service for
their starlink satellites for their
communication satellites they put a
clause in there about how they would
regulate Mars and that Mars I mean and
so you can say it's a joke but that was
a legal instrument that went out I bet
it was not a joke thousands of people
right so you know the funny thing about
law is that you don't know what things
are going to crystallize you know what I
mean and there are some things in law
for instance in international law where
if you don't object you are bound
um right so people can come up with all
kinds of crazy things and you don't even
end up so so even though that's far out
but it's still there but of course what
we are talking about is since the rise
of Mega constellations which is
basically
companies and entities establishing
these constellations of thousands of
satellites yeah right because satellites
have now become super small and cheaper
to launch and instead of one massive one
billion dollar satellite you can launch
like 100 small ones and so this is the
trend now so when you look at the fact
that if you look at the United Nations
register of objects that have been
launched since 1950 there are about 11
000 objects on there okay and just
SpaceX alone today have licenses for 40
000 satellites
right so one company has more licenses
to launch satellites that have been on
the register of launch space objects
since the 1950s so that goes to show
where we're going right and so yes how
do we regulate these Mega constellations
how do we think about what are the
implications of all of a sudden low
earth orbit that is the orbit close to
Earth being populated by thousands and
thousands of satellites so that is the
priority right now
Regulatory and governance standpoint and
then secondly
space situational awareness and Space
Traffic management how do we know what
is going on in that environment and what
are the right-of-way rules like if two
satellites are coming close together who
has to move we don't have things like
that because we only had 11 000
satellites in space
well also not to be too much of a
physicist but you know I I once took a
boating lesson and I was told to you
know move to the right uh in the
right-of-way rules but in space there's
no such thing as to the right there's
this up and down and I don't even know
how we're going to resolve the symmetry
of the situation here
yeah I mean I mean we did it with
Aviation right like that's true I mean
it's just it's it's just no one really
it's been difficult because people we
have the concept of the freedom of outer
space yeah right and this concept that
space is like The High Ground And so
whoever dominates in space has some kind
it's kind of like nuclear right like
it's some kind of superpower and so you
know having an international Authority
or having or States giving up their
rights has been something that has been
hard for us you know some of these super
power states to get their head around
but what's happened with increased
commercialization is it's just not going
to function yeah if we don't have rules
of the road and let me just so I
understand better the implications of
these 40 000 satellites that SpaceX has
a license to to put up there are they
just completely passive and moving in
fixed orbits or do they have little tiny
rocket engines on them so they could
adjust
yeah so I mean when you look at
um when these small satellites first
came like when the Innovations first
happened you know many of them people
kind of thought was space junk already
because they they only last they they
last like a year or something and there
was no propulsions there was no what do
you call it
um
um navigation system or anything like
that so people were like this is just
like a disaster waiting to happen with
all these tiny little satellites running
around unmaneuverable but the technology
is advancing right because this is
becoming mainstream so they I'm sure
SpaceX satellites are maneuverable I
mean I don't want to speak about the
technology or how it works because I
have no clue but with everything going
on I think no one is going to be
designing satellites right now that you
can't really maneuver
um mind you you saw in the news there
was all this stuff recently about this
Chinese satellite that was coming
Crashing Down to Earth and things or
rocket bodies that that like there's a
threat of them so some people are
choosing to abide by Best Practices
um but there's nothing forcing them to
yeah and the risk is still pretty
minimal of any damage like happening to
say a human or a property at the moment
but clearly we know the risk is going to
increase well I read a number that was I
forget exactly what it was for maybe
maybe you'll have a better number but
the the chance that if you're up there
in a space station or whatever that you
will be impacted by a passing piece of
pace junk to something like one in 300
which is on the one hand small but on
the other hand pretty big and it's only
going to get worse right like one in 300
chances happen kind of often
yeah I mean I mean for me I don't think
it's about the past I think it's about
the future yeah right it's about you
look at the trend and you look at where
we're going
um and yeah SpaceX had licenses for
forty thousand Rwanda has licenses for
300 000. okay
just to start right you know yeah yeah
and and speaking of Rwanda I do want to
talk about even before getting too much
into the private corporations the good
old nation states and their role here I
mean how many yeah countries have active
space programs
yeah at least the last I looked at least
70. wow right and those and they are
um you know when people think of a
space-faring country
they obviously think of America yeah
China Russia and America space budget is
like 50 billion dollars
so it they find it hard to imagine
the Philippines with a space budget of
12 million dollars is also a space
country right
and I worked I started my create the
Nigerian space agency and the budget was
100 million dollars
so there's no one can Define what is a
space I mean you can say space-faring
Nation means I have a rocket and I can
launch
very few countries have that or space
faring means I can launch anti-satellite
missiles which is the technology to be
able to blow up basically space weapons
yeah maybe only three or four have that
right but
are you a space foreign country if you
know how to use environmental data that
comes from satellites and you can make
applications
um the UK when they did their study of
their space Market they put like
satellite TV channels
a space some people could argue that's
not space hmm
so that's right is GPS is a GPS device
space
I was going to ask what the federal team
if you want to make your space industry
bigger
then you can add those secondary layers
right to say this device this
application is part of the space
industry whereas others might say no
that's not space industry
so do countries like the Philippines and
Nigeria have satellites or do they use
satellites Nigeria Nigeria had five okay
and they were launched by somebody that
they paid to launch them
yeah uh the first satellite was you know
procured from China Nigeria was actually
China's first International client we
set Nigeria set their international
business so it was it was it was very
interesting
um that was when I was working at the
Nigerian space agency and it's just you
know fascinating because from there
China just went up with respect to the
number of developing countries that they
helped develop their space programs
um and you know what was really
interesting about that experience was
that first cell like failed in orbit
and so Nigerians were so upset yeah they
were like another white elephant project
that you guys are like you know we don't
even know anything about space and
you're going to buy satellites from the
Chinese and they're getting lost in
space you know there's so much
misunderstanding around space technology
the risks what it does what it is and
for me I think the unique thing about
starting my career in a developing
country is I have a bit of a unique lens
in the way I look at space the first
being never underestimate the fact that
um people care or even think space is
remotely relevant or interesting because
space people really are like Manifest
Destiny like we are explorers and I'm
like like you guys get out of your Echo
chamber or whatever because step just
step out there no one has even got a
clue that GPS is from satellites and
that's one of the number one
applications of space or that if you use
the ATM machine your transactions happen
because of satellites people don't know
these things
do you think that developing countries
should pour more money than they are
into space
don't trap me on this one
um
in spending money for the sake of it you
have to be able to articulate
and you have to be able to justify right
and there are studies that kind of say
for every one dollar you spend on space
this is what you get back
um what I believe is clear about space
is
it's marketing and inspirational
potential right so you know the moonshot
ideas I think the word moonshot came
from even space right the whole you set
a goal that is clear that is audacious
and big you set resources to achieve
that goal space is just really good for
that you say to your people we need the
best and the brightest to do this thing
that sounds so unachievable and by
putting your efforts towards that you're
always constantly thinking about how do
we bring this back to Earth how do we
apply this in other areas in other
sectors so if Nigeria said we want to go
to the Moon I don't particularly care
about the moon but I know the first
thing you need aerospace engineering
programs and universities right right
right Primary School students that have
even heard of astronomy
so those are the kind of things that I
like about space
I do like that you know I
we just had the 10th anniversary of
discovering the Higgs boson at CERN at
the Large Hadron Collider and one of the
analogies that was frequently brought up
as to why we should do this why we
should spend 10 billion dollars to find
the Higgs boson is because it's
inspirational much like the space
program was and on the one hand I think
that's true but on the other hand
nothing is quite like the space program
was like that was that was and maybe is
you know it's it's inspirational in a
very tangible different way than finding
a new elementary particle is
right right
um and then people have to remember the
context context matters
we were in the context of a cold war
right in the context of this race for
the world the hearts and minds of the
world right it's very different context
and so you know it's
um if you don't have these contextual
things then it's not people have to
recognize then that a lot of the
inspiration with space comes from
mythology things that are Concepts that
are not even real
right and so it's that mythical nature
of space and
um you know ego and all these things
that made it successful and I'm not
saying that those are the same qualities
I want to imbibe
um moving forward because I don't think
it works today so today the narrative is
all about things like
what are the biggest problems that we're
facing and what can space do to help
solve them this is jumping way ahead of
where I want it to be but
do you are you sympathetic to the idea
that we should spread human life onto
other planets as part of a safety
mechanism to make sure nothing bad
happens to the only intelligent life we
know about in the universe
absolutely not okay
it's very resilient
I think that
that energy should be placed on making
sure that whatever it is you're trying
to avoid by going out doesn't happen
Okay okay you know that's
um that's what I think I have completely
nothing against the people who Wanna
go out and explore and and do all those
things I mean I am a Cosmopolitan right
I've lived in five different countries
because
um I know that every time I've moved
countries I've developed myself I've
gained A New Perspective so why not go
to Mars why not do all those things yeah
sure right got it I think I think I
understand that's a very good
distinction to draw
um but before we move on I just want to
get you mentioned that there's lots of
countries that have space agencies but
it's also pretty top heavy right like
who are the major players in literally
launching rockets and satellites into
space
yeah okay so the ones that everyone has
heard about Russia China the us then you
have India the UK Canada
right Italy Germany France you're you
know European countries
um a lot of them have space programs and
then you know Japan so all of the major
countries all of them have space
programs
um but interestingly
the majority of countries are from a
developing ones
that have space programs right and all I
don't want to say developing I don't
know what developing means but emerging
um or middle countries like the United
Arab Emirates or Saudi Arabia
um Egypt like these countries all have
space programs too and it's very diverse
I mean the United Arab Emirates
allocated 800 million dollars to space
last year and you know I just saw this
proposals for this lunar Colony kind of
like space
um tourism activity in Dubai that is
based on Space which is gonna cost five
billion dollars again do we call that
space industry
right I mean they might say so because
it's part of the inspiration about like
having this massive Luna Colony that
shows that space activity that shows
what life on the Moon could look like I
mean is that space or is that
entertainment or is that education I
don't know how you want to frame it but
it it does point in the direction of why
it behooves us to get our ducks in a row
vis-a-vis governance and space law and
things like that it's going to be a mess
if we don't figure out what the rules
are ahead of time
yeah because the environment is
completely Diversified I mean we
um so can you can imagine when the laws
were created we had two actors yeah
only two today we have 80 countries we
have private companies we have
universities right like students are
sending things up there on their own
um so it's completely Diversified and so
if and and completely connected to Earth
so if we don't if we don't think about
governance as it evolves and as part of
that the key issue of governance is
sustainability right because that's the
one thing we did not have when we were
developing all the other governance
regimes in the history of the world
right was to think from the beginning
that human impacts every every activity
human impacts it and it impacts the
ecosystems the people around the social
justice issues right so sustainability
needs to be built in from the start and
space is one of the unique places that
if we are serious we can really use it
as a model
oh explain what explain what you mean by
that
um
people believe there's going to be
a massive economy in space that means
infrastructure
right if we find resources up there that
means space mining
right if they believe in these
settlements
all those things need governing rules
that haven't been developed yet
so are we just gonna develop them in the
same way we've developed all the other
rules or do we say okay let's look at
how mining is regulated and let's look
at all the environmental impact from
mining let's look at the social justice
issues the human rights and violations
and all that and let's see how we can
avoid that if we are going to have this
new economy in space and I guess the
worry is that while we're trying to
think about this someone just rushes out
there and does things so I mean maybe
this is a good chance to talk about the
private initiatives in space and we all
know about SpaceX and you mentioned the
constellations of satellites but there's
other players in this field
yeah I mean there's new there's there's
a lot of activities now around you know
how you do dress the sustainability
issues so
um
how would you do on or a bit
I've forgotten what it's called like
fixing satellite satellite Servicing
right so you know instead of just
sending a satellite up there and then
when the fuel is gone it's gone can we
actually do you refueling so you have
orbit Fab who are like a refueling
company and then you have like Astro
scale who are a deorbiting company like
to bring your satellite down
um so there are all kinds of activities
around the sustainability thing
um and then I mean those are the ones
that I am you know most familiar with
but
um and then there are ideas kind of
around energy so
how do we figure out how to use the
energy right of the sun oh yeah what
they call it space powered solar powered
engine energy or whatever so there are
some ideas around things like that yeah
and are those well I I was going to say
are these companies generally playing by
the rules but maybe you should first
tell us what the rules are I know
there's some un treaties but are are
there accepted
statutes of space law that everyone
agrees to
yeah so I mean we have like what
everyone knows about is the general
Constitution like document which is the
outer space treaty that basically gives
the overarching principles about how
States should operate and
companies are kind of off the hook
because unlike areas of international
law generally space activities of
private companies are directly
attributable to the state okay
so
um states are responsible for any
activity oh so it's very it's very
complex for a stay
right and even things like liability
like the liability Provisions the
liability convention that covers if
there's any damage that is covered by
space activities got nothing to do with
the private company that is that has the
activity it's purely the state how do
you figure out what state is responsible
for what a company does
yeah so the launching State first of all
you have to figure out who is the
launching State okay and there's four
criteria for launching State the the the
country who physically launches the
activity or who procures the launch of
activity or whose facility you know so
you you you look for a launching State
and then there's also a state of
registry which is the state that puts on
the United Nations register that this
satellite is from our country and they
should know all that because those
people would have to have gotten a
license
from the country so the country should
know all the satellites or space objects
that are registered under its registry
and is that part of the space read or
some other law that you have to register
to put a satellite in orbit yes so the
registration convention which is the law
that applies to satellite which maybe
only has 70 or 80 signatories out of the
over a hundred that have signed the
outer space treaty so not everyone is a
signatory to the registration convention
says that you have to register as soon
as practicable ah
so you could say probably a lot of spy
satellites have not been registered not
practical because it's not practical
this is the thing about law right like
you have these strong obligations and
then they'll like put
if possible
and have the companies uh generally been
obeying the rules that do exist
yes I I would say so I mean because they
they were only required to do what their
license requires okay right so
um and just this week you know stuff has
come out the FCC Federal Communications
Commission and now saying that before
there was like a rule of something like
25 years that your satellite can just
hang around there and now it's like five
years oh okay you know
um so it it all comes down at the end of
the day the way private companies abound
is through the licensing procedure
now what's really interesting is not all
activities have a licensing procedure
yet
okay so for instance
if you if you want to do space mining
where'd you go to get a license
I don't know you know like if you if you
want to launch an earth observing
satellite a satellite that has a camera
that looks on Earth you go to NOAA the
oceanic Administration office and you
get a license if there's going to be a
camera on there there's like a different
kind of license because I mean not a
camera like a video because I remember
once someone wanted to do video from
Space sure
so then they had to think about well is
the video the same as the camera
do corporations have spy satellites of
Their Own
so Corporation I mean they're not going
to call it spy satellites but they
corporations I mean the Iraq War
was called the first space War
because that war was like completely
enabled like for the first time told me
by satellite technology
but I'm just wondering if and some
interesting things happen like there's
like rules called shutter control so
like these companies abound by like
because space is a national security
thing if the government kind of turned
the government want to know everyone
that has bought imagery from you
um and I think during one of these wars
the the U.S government ended up getting
like a sole contract so they this don't
sell it we will give you a contract to
buy out all the data
so that you won't sell it to anyone else
they do things like that yeah it's good
to be the government do you think that
being uh one of these space-faring
companies is lucrative right now are
they base are they more interested in uh
getting prepared for the future
the margins are pretty small yeah it's
expensive to do stuff
yeah the margins are pretty small but
some people can see an outsized
um
competitive advantage through marketing
for instance like because for some
reason if you say you're a space company
people think that's Innovative like if
you see over the during covet it was
crazy with all the specs right with all
the investment that just saying you're a
space company like no one cares about
the returns what are you actually doing
it was just like we just got a ton of
money in the space industry because it's
like space you know and and and and so
you know I'm doing my MBA right now
because I'm just like you know what I
can't be one of those people that's like
a space person that doesn't know like
what a financial statement means and
like you know what return on investment
means and you know because you talk to
all these space people that are just
like I've been watching Star Trek since
I was two yeah
yeah
yeah
and I'm like yeah that doesn't mean you
can run a space company
so I mean
are they are is the income that the
space companies do get is it mostly from
government contracts or are they you
know hiring themselves out to other
companies who want some space info
yeah so I mean
there is a myth that space
commercialization is just now because
we've had telecommunication satellites
since the 19s right right and so that
has been where most of the money has
come from so like television you know
Broadcasting
um through satellite telephony even
Earth observation is like a new market
sure right like when the landsat
environmental satellite came out in the
US they tried to commercialize it and
just no one was buying so they ended up
making it free and then and then tons of
people were using landsat data and then
really it's only in the last you know 10
15 years where we've also added data
analytics to that business model because
people are like I don't know what to do
with all this data I can't even read it
and there are markets for instance like
um oh it's skipping me radar right that
Canada is famous for you know how many
people can read radar data it's not even
Optical right it's like so now you have
Analytics
people are like okay I don't care that
it's satellite
I care that I have the information that
big location based Services was a big
one where companies were basically just
being like we can tell you how much
revenue your competitor is making by
watching the car Parks right right the
parking lots and you know extrapolating
by how many cars are there how much
revenue your competitor is making
so these are the kind of new activities
that that came up commercially over the
last like 10 20 years and I guess it's a
good place to segue into rather than
what the law is and what companies are
doing right now but maybe what the
principles should be behind yeah this
kind of thing I mean there's probably
some utopian view that space is a common
good that we should all be sharing and
then there's probably some Down to Earth
views that no I want my bit of it
yeah this is called Lex Veranda lexolata
is what the law is Lex faranda is what
the law should be
um the first thing is there's a lot of
confusion about these two principles
because people merge the two and at the
end of the day
you can only rely on what law is
and you can dream about what law should
be
um and so I have three things that I
focus on when I think about the Lex
Veranda
um and the first one is that no
regulation in every other area of
international law pretty much leads to
exploitation right over exploitation so
we like to say well space is like the
high seas right anyone can go and fish
and you know the fish doesn't belong to
anyone but there are so many regulations
about fish stocks yeah right
um and so you know the capitalists who
are kind of like well you know we should
be able to go do what we want it doesn't
make sense in the long term
the second so that means the first thing
is yes we need more laws yeah and I'm
not just saying that just because I'm a
lawyer
thing is we have to look at space and
this is what I presented at the
scientific Institute as a complex system
that is adaptive because you know we we
don't like it's very complex as you're
adding all these actors and all these
activities that no one fully understands
whatever regime you have
has to be adaptive
to new information
but from the equity standpoint know that
adaptiveness
is kind of a tool for the powerful and
the strong
right like when you're weak you're like
you don't really want to hear someone
say oh we've set rules for everyone to
follow in this game
but you know we can change it whenever
we want
right that's that's a tool for you know
the powerful so the first thing to do is
recognize that it is a complex adaptive
system
um which means by recognizing it that
way we have to consider equity and the
social dimensions and who is affected by
this concept and then my third lecture
under point is benefit sharing so like
you say
um people think that space the the
general opinion
is that space is for the benefit and
interest of all countries and of all
Humanity because it doesn't belong to
anyone
but the challenge is if you have all
these ideas of commercialization and
like settlements how can you do that
without property rights and with our
ownership rights
right it just doesn't modern society
doesn't work without people being able
to say this is mine don't come here or I
can get the police to like put you in
jail
um so you know my only answer I can't
answer how we fix that because that's
like a Humanity problem
is that we should just negotiate a
benefit sharing regime how will we
offset this idea the spaces for Humanity
while allowing people who have the
strength and the resources to capitalize
and do all that but be able to give back
and I have no idea why it's so
challenging for people to think about
this in the space context because
everywhere else
you have benefit sharing even if like if
you decide to you know go mine in
Guatemala
you know you have to pay royalties right
like every mining company has Corporate
social responsibility requirements they
have to like build schools and like give
their workers houses and things like
that
you know the last time I said this
though when I was like I used the
example of Guatemala you know the human
rights people are like funny they don't
even do that
they're supposed to do that
but but that's supposed to do that in
space we don't even want to say we don't
even want to say they're not doing that
they're supposed to do that like we
we're like why should we do that
so the idea would be this is interesting
I've never heard this one before so the
idea would be that if some country the
us or whoever else Nigeria I don't know
sets up a settlement on the moon and
starts I don't know mining it
successfully
um in a commercially productive way you
would want there to be a mechanism by
which the benefits of that were shared
not just amongst the people who did it
but more widely
and I get it that they're gonna say why
should I that's gonna stop commercial
Commerce if I have to give my proceeds
away but
you know I was sitting on a flight on I
was on a plane with somebody I talk
about space everywhere and I was you
know badgering the guy next to me
telling him about this benefit sharing
problem and he told me about section 37
of the Toronto planning act that
basically talked about
um Community benefits so if somebody
wants to build like a high-rise building
in Toronto
in Canada and they get a license that
they can build four stories
and then they figure out oh my God this
place is amazing lots of people will
want to come here so we want to build 10
stories
they have to offset those extra stories
through Community benefit arrangements
to say how will the local environment
because obviously the density is going
to increase there's going to be more
people
than if you just had four levels rather
than ten
so there's more people to serve there's
more people that are going to be upset
or hurt or whatever so there's like
these groups in Toronto that are like
benefit sharing groups that sit and they
say oh maybe we should have more Parks
maybe you guys can give us a school
that's the kind of thing that I think
would make sense like if you are maybe
we can say okay you can have X amount of
these minerals but anything over that
right what are you gonna do to help the
rest of the world and they're really
scared that you're gonna say you have to
give money but I've not seen any
evidence that anyone is gonna say okay
you spent a billion dollars Building
Technology to get to the moon all that
hard work to mind the resources and you
have to give us everything I don't think
anyone's gonna say that
I think what people are going to say is
we see the hard work that you've done
but guess what if that thing is worth a
trillion dollars you cannot keep it all
because it's not yours right it belongs
to humanity so what are you gonna do to
humanity for Humanity
how do you imagine that's what that's
what that's where Corporate social
responsibility came from
what's the best way to potentially get
this into action would it be like a
United Nations kind of thing or an
international treaty
so I put this on Facebook in a space
little group so it's not like a journal
article but I was thinking you know I
was the executive director of the world
Space Week Association which basically
the UN in 1999 established a declaration
that said that we should celebrate space
for one week October 4th or October 10th
every year is World space week okay so I
was the executive director of the
organization that was established
to bring that into effect
so basically when I was executive
director in 2016 I think I had 19
National coordinators around the world
right and they would be in charge of
different countries and then people
would do different kinds of events in
those countries to celebrate World space
so all this was just from a un
declaration that was just a statement
so and that's not a law
and a lot of these people who are doing
these events of volunteers
but I feel like even just a simple
statement like that could set up there
should be an organization like the world
Space Week Association that is for
benefit sharing and people and the first
thing that people are going to say is
who are the beneficiaries
because the difference with the Toronto
planning Act is it's obviously the
citizens of that municipality in Toronto
but in space you're saying Humanity so
who has in law we call it standing right
I think
it's fair enough to say anyone who
self-identifies as being a beneficiary
so like this is the club right the this
is the club this is the space benefits
Club
do you think you're a beneficiary join
the club
and the benefits that we get through
this club may be things like companies
send their swag here or they do
educational programs that online courses
anything like that this is just where
you go to get the benefits
and maybe it's sort of the flip side of
that uh
SpaceX starlink footnote in the contract
that you mentioned where they say this
won't apply on Mars because they want to
you know do whatever they want on Mars
if you if you establish I'm just
spitballing here tell me if I'm crazy if
you establish something like this just
conjecturally aspirationally right now
where there's not trillions of dollars
flowing in and people are willing to say
yes that's a good idea then when the
trillions of dollars start flowing in
you can say well you know we agreed to
this uh in the past so let's try to
stick to it yeah I mean I need I'm the
only person who's ever said this so I'm
not I I haven't thought about it fully
but my model comes from so I'm on the
board of the space generation advisory
Council which I don't know if you've
heard of them is the biggest youth group
um space advocacy program for youth in
the world and that same 1999 declaration
established
this space generation advisory Council
and this is now the biggest youth group
in the world I mean Amazon
when they did their um not Amazon blue
origin when they did their flights of
the billionaires gave space generation
advisory Council one million dollars
that's something
so what I'm saying is this small thing
that wasn't a law yeah that was just a
declaration that we should have this
Youth Organization became
an incorporated company like non-profit
organization
that has the big maybe five to seven
thousand students and young people that
are part of it um
and got one million dollars from one
company
why not do that for a space benefit
organization all right well we'll see I
think that you know once we appear on
this podcast it'll it'll take off I
think this will do it everyone will
agree a lot of influential listeners
um but but this is almost too good you
know the sort of the utopian let's let's
see what we should do kind of attitude
but let's think about like the
challenges we have right now up there in
space you already mentioned space junk
and space debris I mean there's also the
actual possibility of conflict military
conflict or something like that we have
a space force now I don't know what
space force does but I think we have one
yeah yeah so I mean
so that is the one of the focuses right
now on talking about what is responsible
what is responsible behavior in space
what are everyone's talking about what
are the Norms of behavior because right
now it's like I mean for me it seems
pretty clear what is responsible
behavior or not but actually responsible
is depends on who you talk tricky yeah
right like I mean if if a satellite is
coming close to yours
is that an act of War
so no one knows what this means if you
jam someone's signals such that it that
satellite doesn't work temporarily
is that the basis of an attack a
military attack
I don't so we need to clarify the
whether the laws of war apply in the
space context and now that we're talking
about things like space forces the US
didn't they say
that they were responding
to the actions of our adversaries and
setting up the space for us
um but others would say by them
declaring a space force and it being the
most biggest news
is them making they actually made
everyone else have to have a space for
us so escalation works yeah
right so
um so it's definitely definitely a
priority right now and and the
interesting thing is that the US this
year just did that whole thing of you
know saying there should be a ban on
these anti-satellite tests right being
able to blow up satellites
but it's just interesting when countries
say things like this when they've
already spent years developing that
technology and like years doing what
they like and now because other
countries want to do it too they're like
this is bad
the idea now is what we're saying is and
you can tell that they don't think it's
bad because no one is saying that we
shouldn't do it at all people are kind
of saying we shouldn't do it if it
causes space debris huh
it's not like an outright band like
don't do it at all
but it's things like
making declarations that you will not be
the first to blow up someone's satellite
not that you will not blow up someone so
people still want to maintain that
Article 2 and article 51 of the UN
Charter's right to self-defense sure
right because if you completely give up
the ability to test weapons that can be
used in space
um then
if this really is gonna be the place
that is gonna be like a trillion dollar
economy is gonna happen I mean no one is
gonna
rely on just peaceful Goodwill
and I I didn't actually follow it very
carefully but wasn't there a recent
incident where a satellite was was
intentionally blown up was it China I
don't even know
yeah I think the last one was probably
India yeah but the inter I mean China's
done it and when China did it in 2008
that was just crazy because it caused a
bunch of debris
um what people didn't see was the U.S
action in response was rather
interesting I think maybe like a week or
a month later
the U.S
blew up its satellite that they said oh
look it's tumbling out of control
but look we blew it up and there was no
space to be caused
so if you're just looking then you can
because the us are going to say see we
blew up a satellite but we didn't cause
all this debris
others could look at it and be like they
were making a signal on a statement yeah
not just about space debris but like you
can't threaten us we can blow things up
to your capability because not only can
we blow things up we can blow things up
and not have a diplomatic chaos around
it how did they right to blow something
up without getting space debris
so it's all about I guess it's all about
calculating way
okay so it was close enough to the
atmosphere that any debris just blew up
or whatever yeah
all right I'm learning things this is
great
yeah and then it's interesting because I
love the case of India
um because when India started it was the
model
for space for Earth space for
sustainable development none of this ego
driven crap it was like we are
developing space to monitor our
Fisheries to help our firemen our
fishermen
and then what 2016 they had the first
mission to the Moon Chandra mission that
cost something like 50 million dollars
like nothing yeah
and then last year they had an
anti-sabellite test um
so
all that to say is that
Dill seen by most people as
flexing right the rules aren't there yet
so we can use it for symbolic
demonstrations yeah yeah
and and yeah yeah I mean if you looked
at Twitter the Indians did have a lot of
Pride around that as that test yeah I
mean the United States had a lot of
Pride when we put people on the moon
yeah
yeah
and it does it comes back to this the
safety issue right once all this debris
is just the amount of debris is just
increasing and I mean maybe I should ask
how much is the very concept of
safe travel through space uh something
that is very important as far as space
law is concerned I will let me make one
confession which is that of course I
knew about the uh two space shuttle
um disasters the Challenger in Colombia
but I I hadn't ever heard in my little
American bubble of the soyuz 11 disaster
do you know about this one
um the only tell me the only time
officially speaking when people died in
space rather than coming back or going
uh soyuz soyuz 11 visited the first
Russian
uh space station in 1971 and there was
some explosion and all three cosmonauts
died on their way back and they they
landed the the they didn't even know
they lost Communications the spacecraft
landed and then the rescue team knocked
on the door and they were all dead I
didn't I had never heard of that no I
didn't know that yeah so so people have
died in outer space that's what I was
trying to to check but presumably
the first time this happens on a
commercial flight or a mission to Mars
or something like that this is going to
be a very very big news story is this
something we worry about in space
governance circles
yeah I mean
when the first space tourism companies
like virgin were establishing and
there's this class of people called
space flight participants that is the
legal status of these space tourists and
the big thing was
in the experimental licenses that the
states gave to these companies
um the the standard was basically
informed consent so it was basically
saying to the people like these
companies will not be liable in the
event of if you die because you have to
have informed consent
and know what risk that you're getting
into
um
so
and I think there was there's like a
number of years that you give the
company so they say okay you have this
protection for x amount of years
and then we'll re-look at the situation
so that's kind of like
how they work that and then obviously
with that there's enough data that you
can now get the insurance Market in if
possible but of course they need a lot
of data to be able to do anything no one
wants like completely ignorant about the
risks Factor
um but the interesting thing is I'm
actually on the board of a company
called worldview Enterprises which is a
stratospheric balloon company okay
that is a tourism company that is going
to take people to the edge of space so
it's not going to be in microgravity but
it's going to go to the edge of space so
you will be able to see the curvature
space because they kind of realize that
enough people want to go to space but
don't want to sit on a rocket and take
that kind of risk
um but I think they sold a couple of
thousands of tickets to go to the edge
of space so people are definitely
interested but I I don't think people
are interested in that level of risk and
of course they can't afford it but would
you buy a ticket
so worldview Enterprises yes I already
got myself
figured so yes do you have a date or is
it still uh so the first flight so
what's really cool about this is that
they are actually the spaceports that
you will be leaving from from the
wonders of the world so from the
Serengeti from the Great Barrier Reef in
Australia so I'm going from the Great
Wall of China wow and the first ones are
going to be from the Grand Canyon in
Arizona
and that should be by the grace of God
you know in the next couple of years
okay you you mean that's right next to
where you live and you had to go all the
way to China to make this well I'm I'm
not gonna go on the first one okay
fair enough
I'm not that brave let someone else work
out the bugs yes
yeah
um I guess the other thing to talk about
as far as space governance is concerned
is just the uh protection of the
environment out there yeah space which
I'm sure is a huge deal but first remind
us for those of us who have forgotten or
don't know about the tardigrade incident
which I know is kind of fun the Todd so
so the big the closest thing we really
have to environmental law is article 9
of the outer space treaty which kind of
says can't do activities that have
harmful contamination and if you do you
have to consult there's a duty to
consult or and you know but article 9
you know with this harmful contamination
it was more about biological
contamination like you know if you take
a specific bug into space from Earth
will it confuse the science because
people might think that it was a martian
bug right yeah when it's really
something that you took from Earth so
Environmental Protection is mostly been
around planetary protection
that has been a trend recently that
I don't know if you heard about the
ViaSat case so ViaSat took the FCC to
court and basically said that they
should have applied the NEPA act which
is the National Environmental Protection
act to SpaceX satellites that they
should have done environmental impact
assessments on those satellites so
people are trying to say we need to have
more environmental law Concepts but it's
classically been based on planetary
protection and what happened was this
this non-profit organization you know
Arch Arch Mission Foundation basically
put tardigrades these kind of resilient
bugs onto the spacecraft of the bursaret
mission which is an Israeli Mission and
it ended up crashing on the moon and
then they basically came out and said
that they never told anyone that they
put these hard words on the moon so it
was really interesting for us
International lawyers because yeah
NASA's response was there was no breach
of international law
right and it's just like but how can you
how can there have been no wrong
by
putting these bugs onto someone else's
mission that no one knew about and then
they crashed on the moon did they know
that this craft was going to crash on
the moon was that intentional nobody
knew that it was going to crack I mean
they probably it was a risk but it
wasn't meant to crash it wasn't meant to
crash yeah
it wasn't meant to crash but then the
guy came out
Nova is his name basically saying yeah
we would kind of just test the
environment international law and we
didn't do anything wrong so you know
that is the thing about the Innovative
spirit it's just kind of like break it
and then find out
you know what happens later and nothing
happened there was no implication of
that and I guess the idea is that
tardigrades are famously sturdy right
like maybe they could survive on the
moon
for a little yeah I mean they're gonna
say there was no actual risk because the
Moon is not really protective because
pretty much people say there's nothing
on the moon
in terms of life and secondly they like
put it in some kind of resin and it's
like trapped
so the idea is that it's not like they
were just freely floating tardigrades
that were
like alive so then like we didn't
there's no risk yeah we didn't actually
do anything
but it's just interesting when people do
these tests to just figure out the
boundaries of the law
and I mean the the US NASA also doing it
with these
contracts for space resources that
they're using to represent legal
precedence that it's not illegal to do
an inorbit transfer of resources so they
like they awarded a company a contract
for one dollar
right so these guys have got a contract
from NASA to buy a Luna soil
for one dollar
or ten dollars or something like that
and NASA are gonna use that on the
international realm to say this is legal
precedent that it it is not that I can
do an inorbit transfer so there's
someone today is crazy
so so why is that an in-orbit transfer
do they do it in because they will the
company will take the soil and then they
will put it somewhere
and they will tell NASA we have now
given you
through this contract we've given you
this soil it now belongs to you that's a
legal transfer of ownership okay it's
never been done in space and these are
all just trying to establish the
Precedence it's not because anyone cares
about this particular transaction yeah
it's legal precedence is scary and for
me from an international law perspective
sounds a little bit
monopolistic because I mean me an
African company would never have been
able to get a contract for one dollar
because I need money to go there yeah
right to build the spacecraft to be able
to launch it and get there and figure
out the technology to do this so I can't
even be in that discussion about the
legal precedent because you gave someone
a contract for one dollar
I mean realistically
there will be a mess right I mean people
are just gonna go to the moon and claim
it or claim parts of it that's almost
inevitable
yeah maybe I mean if we look at history
yeah yeah if we look at history
um the difference is I think one of the
unique things about spaces is the the
only place where
it it's freaking hard to get to yeah
you know so it it so the challenge is
kind of less
because at the end of the day if one of
these people just decide well we're
going I mean how are you gonna actually
stop them right
I don't know yeah so that's why a lot of
people
would kind of just be like you know what
I'm not even gonna be in this fight and
the thing could just happen by basis of
people just being like this is not even
my fight
but I'm here to tell developing
countries it is your fight because
they've decided that by 2040 space is
going to be worth a trillion dollars ASU
right now is leading a mission to the
first metallic asteroid the psyche
Mission which they say is worth like 10
trillion dollars if you actually figure
out how many resources are there so
Africa it is your fight because don't
come and tell me in 30 years time when
that you've been left behind and then
you want handouts because I'm telling
you right now the space economy is
coming and if you're not at the table
right now before the rules are being
developed you will get left behind and
no one's gonna give you nothing
I guess the other difference is that
unlike other parts of the world there's
nobody living there right so we're not
going to have exactly a replay of
colonialism or or stuff like that but
but probably some of the same issues are
gonna come up because you know as you're
implying the the rich get richer by all
this kind of thing right I mean they're
going to be able to get this what we say
no colonialism in space but coloniality
exists ah okay so colonialism is the
practices
whereas coloniality is the mindset
so all that is because of course the
first thing they'll say is why are you
guys talking about colonialism there's
no indigenous people there right but
coloniality is just as dangerous
right a mindset of manifest destiny
domination even without practices is
harmful
do you think that if a private
corporation based in let us say the
United States
establishes a base on the moon the
United States will claim that as part of
their territory
no they won't claim it as part of their
territory but what I love about these
countries
is that the flag yeah the flag is the
first thing we did the flag is the
symbol of territory
and the flag is what they used to say we
are not claiming territory boom flag
that's what I love about these countries
that's they're gonna say something
and they're gonna use the very symbol
right that
you know that is just like okay
and then what is it right so they say
they say the autumnus Accords
says
you can establish a safety zone
right you can't own this land but you
can establish a safety zone
around your property okay so it's gonna
ask next yeah
right
but it doesn't that they love to say but
it doesn't mean keep out Zone
so I mean
you know and so what but when I talk to
people they say what it means is that
it's a consultation Zone
so like a notification and consultation
zone so there's rules you know if you're
gonna be like 50 50 yards from my spot
we gotta have a discussion yeah
but you use the word safety zone and
then you tell people why do you think
that means a keep out zone of course
they're gonna think it means to keep out
Zone
right and then they love to say well
when people heard this they just started
speculating before we actually explained
to them and I'm like so why did you just
say it and not explain straight away
when you said oh people can have safety
zones but it's not really a Zone it's
like just no they said safety zone
silence for like three months yeah they
let people speculate and think all these
crazy things and then they come out and
say what do you guys talk talking about
I guess I mean maybe one I'm not against
the US's position by the way yeah no I I
do get it um
maybe the last thing to to just to get
on the table is you know how realistic
all this talk is like you said it's very
hard to get to space uh it's dangerous
right the Actuarial tables do not look
good if you think about uh the dangers
associated with going to space and we
already have you know things here on
Earth you know we have the bottom of the
ocean we have Antarctica that are pretty
hard to get resources from Etc even
though they might be there so I mean is
is this something we're we're
realistically talking about for your my
lifetime people getting resources from
space and bringing them back down here
not bringing them back down here but
everyone is talking about in-situ
resource utilization okay right finding
resources in space to help us be able to
stay in space and not have to take
things from Earth to space
so I mean already 14 countries have said
their plans
right
um the U.S Artemis program that just
launched you know last week
is essentially the whole point of it is
to establish a permanent presence in
space
so
by virtue of the fact that I mean the
International Space Station was the
first permanent presence in space
but now we're going to have them in
stationary locations mm-hmm
and so I mean if you look at Antarctica
where people have that
no one has decided to live an Antarctica
permanently they still see it as like
they they have territories there and
they have scientific outposts
so the question is is space just going
to be like that where it's like yeah a
bunch of people have like scientific
outposts so maybe I mean I think NASA's
plan is one thousand the US's plan is 1
000 people a year
living in space living in space oh okay
I didn't know that yeah
something like that so that's satellites
or on them is that on the moon or on
satellites yeah yeah yeah something like
that or I think maybe the UAE might be
the only country that actually has in
its strategy actually about people
living and working has been so some
countries do have it but it may not be
like when we imagine like cities in
space it may be like these outposts like
in Antarctica
that I can foresee very easily
would you go
absolutely not I'm not going anywhere
near a rocket
so balloons you're okay with rockets are
a little dangerous yeah yeah I think
that's fair all right I always like to
end on an optimistic note and I mean I
think you've portrayed you've given us a
lot of reason to be optimistic anyway
but uh I mean one of the things I like
best about
everything that is implicit in what you
say is just how International and human
and Global the whole thing is and I mean
maybe you just want to put that into
your own words or add something else but
this is ultimately a project for all
humankind not just for this or that
company or country
yeah I mean I I'm sounding like a cliche
and broken record now but I almost
always end my talks with
um the words of Joey Estridge and Ed
Finn from the Center for Science and the
imagination at Arizona State University
and they basically say
space does not avoid
but a canvas for the human imagination
so all the questions about policy
politics Logistics a merely scaffolding
for a deeper set of questions about who
we are and who we want to become as a
species
so we explore the universe not just
because we are curious
but because of what that Curiosity will
do to us
and how we will grow to match our
expanding sphere of understanding
for me that quote just says it all right
space is a construct
space is a product of the imagination it
doesn't have any concrete tangible thing
because if you say to an aerospace
engineer what is space they might tell
you about Rockets if you say to someone
who is
um a data specialist they will tell you
spaces about the vantage point from
Earth if you talked if you talk to an
indigenous person they will tell you
space is about the stars in our
relationship to how we navigate so it's
a construct
and that's why as somebody in the school
for the future of innovation in society
I look at space space as really not
really a technological challenge but a
sociological one
cannot improve on that to me again about
thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast thank you
[Music]
la la la
[Music]